The sounds of 1930s Paris fill the room at this coffeehouse in Florida.
The Cook Trio specializes in Gypsy Jazz.
Jason Cook is the group's lead guitarist.
It's very happy and it's not a very subdued play... way of playing.
It's very over the top...
...you know, it's like true guitar music, you know.
Gypsy Jazz originated in France during the 1930s.
Guitarist Django Reinhardt was instrumental in developing the style,...
...having grown up in gypsy camps near Paris.
Today's Gypsy Jazz musicians imitate Reinhardt,...
...who played alongside violinist Stephane Grappelli in the group Quintette du Hot Club de France.
Reinhardt played guitar chords with just two or three fingers.
Other Gypsy Jazz musicians do as well.
The Cook Trio's Kyle Jones says Reinhardt's music is notable...
...for its distinctive, fast-paced, rhythmic, guitar strumming known as "La Pompe".
The guitar, you know, pushes the whole thing.
It's, you know, like a pulse, you know, they call it "The Pump".
It really is like the pulse of the music that drives it forward.